Die Arktis oder umgangssprachlich: Der Nordpol,
eisfrei?
What?
“Das, was in der Arktis passiert, bleibt
nicht auf die Arktis beschränkt”.
Diese Warnung der Vereinten Nationen (UN)
ist in ihrer Eindringlichkeit nicht mehr zu
überbieten.
Konkret geht es um die drastische Erwärmung
der Arktis, die demnach schon jetzt nicht
mehr zu verhindern ist.
Und nicht nur das: Laut der neuen Studie könnte
die Arktis ab den 2030er-Jahren im Sommer
eisfrei sein - mit gravierenden Folgen für
die GESAMTE Erde.
Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
„Wir haben die Wissenschaft.
Es ist höchste Zeit, dass wir JETZT dringend
handeln.
Denn nur Klimaschutzmaßnahmen können bevorstehende
Umkehrpunkte abwenden, die für unsere Erde
viel schlimmere Folgen haben könnten als
wir bislang gedacht haben” - so heißt es
von der stellvertretenden Umweltdirektorin
der UN, Joyce Msuya.
Damit nimmt sie Bezug auf die gerade veröffentlichte
Studie des Umweltprogramms der Vereinten Nationen
(UNep).
Demnach schmilzt das Arktis-Eis sehr viel
schneller als gedacht.
Um drei bis fünf Grad Celsius könnten die
Winter-Temperaturen in dieser Region bis zur
Mitte des Jahrhunderts ansteigen.
Schon jetzt liegt die Temperatur dort deutlich
über dem langjährigen Durchschnitt - und
zwar um knapp drei Grad.
Auf dem Rest der Erde wurde eine Erwärmung
um ungefähr ein Grad festgestellt.
Der Grund dafür, dass sich die Arktis stärker
als andere Regionen der Erde erwärmt, liegt
Fachleuten zufolge an der sogenannten “arktischen
Verstärkung”.
Im Polarmeer und dem grönländischen Eisschild
gibt es immer weniger Fläche, die von Eis
bedeckt ist.
Doch die eisfreien Flächen auf Land und im
Meer reflektieren das Sonnenlicht sehr viel
weniger, sondern absorbieren die Energie stattdessen.
So erwärmen sich die Regionen immer weiter.
In der Fachsprache wird dieser Effekt der
Reflektivität als “Albedo” bezeichnet.
Verstärkt wird dieser Effekt durch Ruß und
Staub, die bei Waldbränden in Sibirien und
Kanada entstanden sind und sich auf dem grönländischen
Eis ablagern.
Auch dies führt dazu, dass das Sonnenlicht
deutlich weniger reflektiert wird.
Die Folgen in der Arktis sind schon jetzt
enorm.
Beispielsweise tauen die Permafrostböden,
die normalerweise ganzjährig gefroren sind.
Laut einer Langzeitstudie des Alfred-Wegener-Instituts
aus Bremerhaven ist die Bodentemperatur zwischen
2007 und 2016 im Mittel um 0,3 Grad Celsius
angestiegen.
Der Untergrund gibt somit nach und gefährdet
die Stabilität von Straßen und Gebäuden.
Zudem hat das Ganze explosive Folgen für
uns alle - und das im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Denn durch das Tauen der Permafrostböden
wird Gashydrat frei, das im Boden eingelagert
ist.
Das Gemisch ist gefroren und besteht aus Methan
und Wasser.
Wenn es erwärmt wird, explodiert es.
In Sibirien gab es bereits enorme Detonationen,
von denen riesige Krater zurückbleiben.
Aber auch das Erdklima muss darunter leiden,
denn das Tauen des Permafrostes setzt letztendlich
gigantische Mengen an Kohlendioxid und Methan
frei, die zu den langlebigen Treibhausgasen
zählen und zur Erderwärmung beitragen.
Konkret wird durch das Tauen der Böden eine
große Menge Biomasse aus abgestorbenen Pflanzen
frei, die dann durch Bodenbakterien zersetzt
wird.
Und bei diesem Prozess entsteht Methan und
Kohlendioxid - und das nicht zu knapp.
Nicht umsonst wird das Schmelzen des Permafrosts
in der Arktis als sogenannter Kipppunkt bezeichnet.
Rückkopplungs-Effekte im globalen Klimasystem
also, die am Ende dafür sorgen, dass sich
die Erwärmung der Erde selbst verstärkt.
Und im schlimmsten Fall dann unumkehrbar wird.
Und schon jetzt sind Folgen deutlich.
Laut der aktuellen Studie der Unep hat sich
die arktische Meereis-Fläche in den letzten
40 Jahren (seit 1979) um 40 Prozent verringert.
Klimamodelle prognostizieren, dass die Arktis
in in den Sommern ab den 2030er-Jahren sogar
eisfrei sein wird.
WENN wir Menschen weiterhin so viele Treibhausgase
ausstoßen wie bisher.
Doch selbst, wenn wir eine enorme Erwärmung
der Arktis schon jetzt nicht mehr verhindern
können, liegt es doch in unserer Hand, zumindest
die Spitze des Temperaturanstieges zu kappen.
Die aktuellen Berechnungen der UN zeigen außerdem,
dass die Eismassen der Arktis zu einem Drittel
verantwortlich sind für den Anstieg des globalen
Meeresspiegels.
Laut der UNep-Studie könnten allein in den
arktischen Gebieten vier Millionen Menschen
- hauptsächlich aus eingeborenen Völkern
- betroffen sein.
Doch nicht nur dass: Denn dass der Anstieg
des Meeresspiegels für die meisten Länder
dieser Erde fatale Folgen haben wird - darüber
haben wir hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
schon oft berichtet.
Und als wäre das nicht schon genug: Der Temperaturanstieg
in der Arktis könnte indirekt auch dazu führen,
dass bei uns in Europa, aber auch in Nordamerika
und Russland extreme Kältewellen drohen.
Denn die Luftströmung des sogenannten Polarwirbels
schwächts sich durch die nachlassende Eisbeckung
des Polarmeeres phasenweise ab.
Das kann dazu führen, dass kalte polare Luftmassen
nach Süden ziehen.
Auch darüber hatten wir Anfang des Jahres
berichtet!
Und so warnt auch der finnische Umweltminister
Kimmo Tilikainen: “Die Dringlichkeit, die
Ziele des Pariser Abkommens zu erreichen,
zeigt sich eindeutig in der Arktis, denn sie
ist eine der am stärksten gefährdeten und
sich rasch verändernden Regionen der Welt.
Wir müssen die Treibhausgasemissionen, (...) und
andere Klimaschadstoffe in der ganzen Welt
kurzfristig erheblich reduzieren.”
Ein Ergebnis der aktuellen Studie macht eine
Sache noch einmal extrem deutlich.
Nämlich, dass es nicht nur höchste Zeit
ist, JETZT zu handeln, sondern dabei auch
langfristig zu denken.
Denn selbst, wenn wir ab sofort Emissionen
einsparen, würden die Wintertemperaturen
in der Arktis in den nächsten zwei Jahrzehnten
ansteigen.
Die Folgen der vergangenen Jahre.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Selbst wenn
die bestehenden Verpflichtungen des Pariser
Abkommens erfüllt werden, dürfte der arktische
Permafrost im Vergleich zu heute um 45% schrumpfen.”
Die Fragen liegen auf der Hand: In welcher
Welt wollen wir leben?
Wie wollen wir unseren Nachkommen die Erde
überlassen?
Wollen wir das wirklich alles zulassen?
Auch die Antworten sind klar: #FridaysforFuture.
Und so steht fest: Schule Schwänzen für
das Klima ist eine gute Sache.
Denn das Engagement der jungen Leute hat schon
jetzt Einiges bewegt.
Und da hat der frühere US-Präsident Barack
Obama Recht: Den Kampf gegen die Klimaerwärmung
kann man nicht “den alten Leuten überlassen”.
Bei seinem Besuch in Köln Anfang April sagte
er wortwörtlich: "Ihr würdet euren Großvater
niemals darüber entscheiden lassen, was ihr
anzieht oder welche Musik ihr euch anhört.
Aber ihr lasst ihn darüber entscheiden, was
mit der Umwelt geschieht, in der ihr leben
werdet?"
Ein Aufruf also, gegen den Klimawandel einzutreten
und sich zu engagieren.
Schließlich ist der Klimawandel “nichts,
was in 50 Jahren stattfindet. er geschieht
genau jetzt".
Klimawandel und Co.
- Alles Manipulation?
Da geht Florian Schröder satirisch an das
Thema.
Draufklicken, anschauen und natürlich | Schroeders
Satirekanal abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran.